and our shutout tonight is for a brave
journalist trying to cover the news and
hold officials accountable in a very
difficult place to do that Ukraine the
country is very much in the news with
the revelations about president Trump
asking for a favor from the Ukrainian
president but long before the world's
media began to focus on the country and
its corruption a small group of
journalists in Kiev had dedicated
themselves to bringing the truth to
Ukrainians including one young woman who
has put herself very much on the
frontlines nastiest acos career in
journalism has already seen her called a
hero a traitor and a liar she's been on
the frontlines of war has been
threatened with death been held hostage
confronted both Moscow and her own
government in Kiev all of that at the
age of 33 given all the pressure and
given the threats and the danger hmm you
still want to be a journalist given
everything when you live in such country
as Ukraine it's always you you always
you know have this feeling that it's not
boring it can be boring now the deputy
editor-in-chief of the Ukraine
television station she helped to found
stock oh says she chose journalism as a
teenager after seeing reports of a
television camera man for Reuters killed
in Iraq by US forces which claimed his
camera looked like a weapon it was 2003
as I remember and I saw it's very
important to be such an dangerous places
and say the people truth from such
dangerous place and places and I said I
want to be younger and she did not have
to travel far to find a war to cover it
came to her when Russian back forces
turned parts of Ukraine into a war zone
hot spot five years ago and then she was
taken hostage by the Russian back forces
they took me to this basement with
something in my hat I mean it's to us
like some coat because that I shouldn't
see nothing well
well we are going and of course they
said that maybe they will cut my hat
something like this when Nastya was
released after a few days she was hailed
as a hero for her courage under such
trying circumstances but then a few
years later when she produced this
report documenting how Ukraine's own
security services have their own secret
prisons the same people who had called
her our hero now said she was a traitor
giving the Russians ammunition to
criticize the Ukrainian government
people should know it's not ok because
it's illegal you know
and this true can help Stanko and her
reporting team tracked down people who
had been held in the secret compounds
who identified key details of the cells
where they were held and some of the
people who served as their guards and
thence tackle confronted the top
officials who had earlier denied the
existence of any such secret prisons you
see this is ten people telling outright
lies to the international organization
because they were recruited by for
example the Russian Federation
now with Ukraine at the center of
attempts in the US Congress to impeach
President Donald Trump Stanko has
another big story on her hands you know
and it's very scary but Sacco says it's
no time to ease up even as she faces new
criticism that her reporting will only
weaken the Ukrainian president and
helped the Russians this is how Stano
put it when she was honored by the
Committee to Protect Journalists with
their international press freedom
it's difficult to walk when you are
expected to choose between majorities
and professional journalism standing
here in front of my colleagues from all
around the world I know this pressure is
not something only we Ukrainians feel
it's pressure experienced by anyone who
chooses journalism as their profession
but I also know that there are is no
need to chose honest journalism is the
best form of patriotism
so our shout out tonight for Nastya
Stockholm and her colleagues in Ukraine
for showing all of us what good
journalism is all about something is
needed evermore in both Kiev Washington
and around the world that's our program
for tonight thanks for joining us we'll
see you back here on the law on crime
Network next week